to make pencil sharpeners they start
with high carbon steel for the blades
the steel unwinds through a straightener
then a feeder serves it up to a punch
cutter it cuts out five blades in one
action complete with assembly holes in
the center
a worker distributes the blades onto a
conveyor that will take them to an oven
the blade slowly circle in the oven this
step takes 15 to 20 minutes exposure to
the intense heat and a quick cool down
in oil harden the blades but it also
leaves them tarnished
so they drain the oil by spinning the
blades in a perforated drum then they
add a mix of dried corn and polishing
paste to the blades
the drum tosses the blades in the
polishing medium for six to twelve hours
a circular feeder sorts them into a
single file and racks them on a metal
rod once on the rod a machine grinds a
cutting edge into all of the blades at
once
next they manufacture the housing for
the pencil sharpener blades a circular
saw cuts a ridged magnesium bar to the
correct length the magnesium block
stumble into a feeder which funnels them
into a stamping machine machine removes
the pencil sharpener bodies forward to a
drill that bores cone-shaped
pencil-sized holes into them a second
drill carves holes in the top for
screwing the blades into the pencil
sharpener bodies a little metal rod
shoves the pencil sharpener bodies out
of the machine and into a bin a worker
plunges the pencil sharpener bodies into
five chemical baths each bath has a
different formula
the chemicals soften the edges of the
magnesium bodies making the surface
shinier these pencil sharpener bodies
are now ready to receive blades a feeder
system delivers them to an assembly
station the screws funnel into an
automated screwdriver at the assembly
point a mechanism slides the blades into
the pencil sharpener bodies as they
arrive the pencil sharpeners fall into a
bin ready for retail over a century and
a half after its invention the manual
pencil sharpener is still making life
easier and in modern factories the
concept has been home to a fine point